we are however seeing
some republicans very slowly
clearly for reasons of self-preservation
starting to jump ship a little bit with
the wild fraud allegations that donald
trump is making i have two examples for
you today
these are not good people these are
still people who deserve to never vote
again but
work again no they can i apolog they
obviously deserve to vote again that's
not what i meant they deserve to never
work again we're going to start with
former new jersey governor chris
christie
uh backing off of trump's voter fraud
claims which are of course
bogus christie a top ally of donald
trump
helped donald trump helped it was a
loose term but worked with trump on
debate prep
and yesterday chris christie said you
know you can keep saying voter fraud and
if there's voter fraud then we need to
deal with it
but you've got to produce some evidence
here and um
chris christie starting to distance
chris christie it should not have to be
said counting absolutely balance is not
illegal it is not fraud it is not
corruption
george let's say i've been fortunate
enough to be on the ballot
a number of times myself i've won i've
lost and so as a candidate you're even
more invested in the integrity of the
system
right so if this stuff is going on that
the president's talking about
all of us want to fart it out because it
would undercut everything that we
believe in in our system
but as a prosecutor that's like asking
me to indict someone
without showing me any evidence if
you're gonna say those things from
behind the podium at the white house
it's his right to do it it's his right
to pursue legal action
but show us the evidence we we heard
nothing today about any evidence
i want to know what backs up what he
said so that i can analyze it and let me
tell you
if he's right i'll be outraged and i'm
sure you would be too if he's wrong
and if he's wrong then the american
people are going to be able to make the
judgment about this election
that the results have been fair and this
kind of thing all it does is inflame
without informing and we cannot permit
inflammation without information so
chris christie
was maybe the first prominent actual
trump adviser
to publicly confront trump and say what
you're saying is not
at least as of now backed up by evidence
it's inflammatory he said he already won
when he didn't
he's saying that there's fraud when
there's no evidence of it you've got to
be careful with that
we then also heard from former
pennsylvania republican senator rick
santorum
now he is not a trump advisor and has
even been a little
lukewarm on trump over the years he is a
republican
that you could reasonably describe as
pro-trump although he has had some
hesitations
he said it was just completely wrong
for trump to undermine public confidence
in the election declare victory all of
that stuff
rick santorum no republican elected
official is going to stand behind that
statement
i mean none of them will uh they will
stand behind
elements of that statement they will
stand behind his
uh comment about the polling and how
he could make the argument that it was
uh
suppression and and dishonest i mean
you can stand behind the lack of
transparency
when it came to allowing the votes to be
canceled
counted there's evidence of that he
provided some evidence for that
there are certain things they will stand
behind in that statement because
they reflect the reality but much of
that statement
was was not was not
factual and was
at times incendiary uh and
uh and not something that president
united states should say or any elected
officials
you said yes you have evidence to to
prove it and
and at this point in time we don't and
we won't
until there is an an investigation as to
what to happen and for
i got to tell you i sat there and i
listened to him talking about
the votes being taken away from him
and then he shifted to arizona and said
you know hey i can win i win this thing
if they count the votes
well how can you how can you say we have
to wait and count the votes in arizona
and i can win this thing we're making it
but if you count the votes in
philadelphia you're stealing them
uh the reality is in pennsylvania
democrats voted by mail and republicans
voted by
uh in person it's because you asked them
to do so
shortly uh after trump wrapped up
that bizarre press conference santorum
also said that the president's rhetoric
was dangerous
and um i think what's important to
remember here
uh is that these are not good people
because they're doing this
chris christie supported trump
throughout the entire campaign
and even helped to manufacture this
exact situation this is a really
important point
chris christie now says oh you know
trump's got to be careful he's got to
bring the evidence
christie facilitated the current crisis
situation which donald trump has has uh
fomented these people are merely trying
to self-preserve
but they all need to go and at some
point we'll put together a full list of
these people
uh chris christie kaylee mckennany of
course you know don jr ivanka kushner
steve bannon the whole lot of them
deserve to never work again these are
facilitators for the most dishonest and
weaponizedly incompetent presidency
that we have had in the modern era like
i could probably
say of all time but let's just say in
the modern era
and um i i hope everybody's been taking
names let me put it that way one of our
sponsors today is
vincero watches and they're giving you
15
off everything in the store if you're a
guy looking for the perfect way
to refresh your style one of the best
investments you can make is in a high
quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top
quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it you'll get
15 off everything in their store when
you go to davidpakman.com
watch and i've put that link right
underneath this video